[Music]
and keep it to yourself news keep it to
yourself buddy
submitted by double standards yup I like
double standards so many double
standards is worth I wish we could
protect all double standards true a High
School assistant principal apologized
after he is overheard calling the female
students skanky hos you call them skills
over the PA system girls please report
the office I love you added that in you
said how I was picturing that how do you
get overheard saying something unless
it's over the PA system I have a C on
this home that is perfectly okay no use
at all okay well then it's not in the
privacy stuff so they were dancing and
they had this on like an over oversized
baseball shirt that's janky with black
shorts I was like a school of that it
was like for homecoming week like a pep
rally or something
yeah I don't see any skank miss gone I
mean yes so then they were just wearing
this oh man they're so stinking only
been to my high school that [ __ ] is
covered up that [ __ ] his [ __ ] cat
look at my high school dude yes he ended
up calling them skanky hos but so that
was initially what was being said
because someone put that on Facebook and
they were just I call him so appalled
that the assistant principal would call
them visible oh wait they didn't even
hear themselves somebody just said it
and they believed it uh well he admitted
to it too
what why would you do that is the night
to the end you [ __ ] [ __ ] yes well he
is because he apologized for it and all
that stuff too so apparently the context
behind this is that he was saying that
they should either cover it up or open
it up I'm not sure exactly what it's
like so he was instructing the step to
ensure the girls jerseys were left open
and their tank tops were visible so
people wouldn't view them in an
appropriate manner
thankee ho yeah but it fit that's fine
nobody's in they should open it up you
dust thanks stanky danky hose but isn't
it being skanky oh he's using reverse
psychology saying the girl should pull
the pants down so they g-string yo be
visible to not kinky hose but within
this context - he didn't call anybody a
skanky ho though well that's what people
are saying so like though someone in the
dance team they said that cuz they can
actually like directly told staff to do
this or whatever and so when they
overheard this they were like so that's
the context of this it doesn't excuse
what he said he still shouldn't said
that yeah you know what I think probably
happened - people are [ __ ] weird I
think it does excuse him I think it does
excuse me I think because what he's
trying to do is he's trying to connect
with them and speak to them in their
language so he's probably like come on
you don't want anyone to confuse us
thank you ho our skanky hos yeah cuz he
didn't call them skanky hos oh let's
just so people don't say that they're
skanky hos that's completely different
yeah that's what I was thinking skills
in English and communication what the
[ __ ] is happening well anything you said
he's thinks he's speaking their language
right yes women it's loose women II know
it's a it's like like a high school
principal today going to some kids and
be like hey guys it's Friday Friday like
what the [ __ ] ya know like that was 10
years ago they're like these kids -
they're thinking that their thoughts and
stuff yeah well I guess it was the whole
fact that that's just something that
shouldn't have even came out of his
mouth like they should have said
something like different words and he
apologized for that he apologized to the
staff I met hos
[ __ ] man you were okay dude
I meant proud of this position in the
school I get it I get it I don't get it
at all I don't cuz that somebody like
that is somebody who we want it to be
our principal yes because yes you know
when you had that teacher that cost
you're like that's a dope teacher so I
wanted someone that was real if you
think he's a human being I would like
this guy's on this guy's [ __ ] real I
hated stiffs yeah hostage
[Music]
controversy thing around this whole
thing oh by the way this is what it
looks like bull spirit sure looks like
[ __ ] Huckabee was important with any
shoulders dude they're little slow P he
has the face and like lower body of
someone that could be buff but his
shoulders just make him so weak yeah
when I was in high school there was a
nationwide news story because our vice
principal at the time she was stopping
girls at the like at the Dorf to go into
the dance I think was homecoming and she
was checking to see if they had thongs
on so she was like lifting up their
skirts and seeing if they had thongs on
why she didn't want girls to wear thongs
cuz they be freak dancing and maybe
actually [ __ ] on like the national
news story
I love adult leopard or was she really
that stupid I wish that if that was the
job of the ASB and I was part of the ASB
and I would have been like let me see
ASB though cuz I feel like they were the
ones that did teacher stuff right do you
think it would have been fair if she had
the thong check for the girls and for
the dudes she would make sure that the
fly of the boxers were button or make
sure guys are wearing underwear at all
yeah cuz a lot of guys don't do that a
lot a lot of guys I knew who were not
good and do that we go in the jam in the
locker room was done I'm like god damn
put on someone to write out a lot of
guys don't wear underwear that's true a
lot of I don't know I don't do that [ __ ]
what's that about yeah stick is rubbing
up constantly change you need a little
bald protection to you don't mean
yeah dude why are you talking about no
so the so then I was supposed to be
hosting because I always hosted the
dance show cuz the dance team wanted me
to host a show every year so I was
supposed to be hosting like a week after
this [ __ ] happened and it's like a
national ministry we have news vans
parked outside of a place doing
satellite things so then I go into the
principal's office because she wanted to
meet with me specifically about this
show that I think don't make fun of it
well yeah exactly
she was like you cannot talk about this
you
not doing anything risque you cannot
mention the word thong if you even say
anything about underwear she told you
please talk about it right I know but
then here's what know here's what she
did though and this is kind of where the
skanky host
she's like if you do any of this Steve I
will mail you to a [ __ ] wall she said
that to me she said the [ __ ] work and
so I was like look at her I was like I
have never been more attracted to you a
man I know I was like hey Mike tip was
saying like when you put a big shiny
button in front of you I just want to
press it and I didn't want to press it
to press it icing it
I definitely bled the line but I did not
say underwear if I pressed every [ __ ]
button I want to do what anyone I get
[ __ ] suspended or nothing I didn't
really care it was just too much fun to
not do those thing I wasn't even gonna
do in the first place but now that you
made yeah that's actually pretty true I
mean I didn't have a plan that was a
lady who we used to play like 13 [ __ ]
the car gave us yeah yeah like big two
ladies came out til she goes you're not
supposed to be playing like she was in
my teacher but she grabbed all the
[ __ ] carts and threw it on the roof
and I was like why'd you litter we have
a major littering problem yeah and so I
was so [ __ ] mad we went to the same
spot the next day I had some other car
she goes didn't I tell you not to I was
like yeah she grabbed it took it away
she grabbed we all had like hella sets
she kept throwing it she's like what I
was like what I was gonna do it's just
[ __ ] car games dude that's right
because the Magister it's like dude if I
how much you wanna bet I can get at each
of the Phillies cars on the roof it's
like I'll [ __ ] way it literally took
one of the security people that taught
there's like yo just leave the kids
alone like what the [ __ ] were we doing
you know what I mean
I can't wait till my teacher Punk's Tyco
[ __ ] you're gonna Punk down yeah yeah
yeah I'm gonna keep the cycle going baby
you're gonna try but then Bart's gonna
die I didn't get let him take the punch
yeah that's good for him let me take the
problem buddy
I want him to get punished I don't see
what either would how he reacts and I
figured after that what if it was a
teacher that was just being power to
specifically talking about a teacher or
like an idiot TA or somebody that's just
power tripping but I'll see if my kids
lying though I'll legit
you know I like tech [ __ ] body cam audio
recording every
I was like you just be yourself and I
want to see how that person reacts cuz I
don't really trust you because I'm a
liar too so you're alive that's what
David David's already not on his kids
team you're already on your kids team
she's the hundred percent of kids
hundred percent on the team and David's
like I think you're a little [ __ ]
lying piece of [ __ ] you know how I know
cuz I raised you and I'm one of those
exactly what the presenter last night I
would figure out every way not to get in
trouble yeah and I'm pretty sure you're
a troublemaker just like I was so let's
see how honest you are now all the
treated the exactly the girl the guy
will have this I respect that I want
them to have the same [ __ ] curfew
because I don't wanna hear [ __ ] from
them okay let me ask you this David your
son wants to go camping with his friends
and they're through like gonna drive
like 45 minutes to an hour away
mm-hmm and they're like 15 and now your
daughter wants to do the same thing I
would say I would say the same [ __ ] I
was like cool I just gotta meet every
[ __ ] boy really you got to know my
[ __ ] face cuz when you [ __ ] my
daughter I'm gonna [ __ ] you what if she
says I'm going on an all-girls camping
trip and you're and then there's on day
same same two different locations you're
both 45 minutes away well hopefully well
this is the thing too hopefully I'm a
decent enough parent where we have a
decent relationship and they could be
honest with me cuz like I'll be okay if
it's like you wanted to be like daddy
I'm gonna [ __ ] today no I'm just hoping
that that's not gonna be the case you
know okay she's like well I like this
boy and we want to be like sexually
active was like cool I still gotta
[ __ ] meet that kid though oh yeah as
long as you're [ __ ] her my face is
right there can't wait to have a kid
yeah I can't either
I just want to throw hypotheticals on
all day I want to call David in the
middle of it
okay David your your your daughter she's
17 she's going to a wedding in Palm
Springs you want to hear this [ __ ] no
I'll pick up a bye Steve let me tell you
real quick go ahead Nicky's gonna be
right they see you could you shut the
[ __ ] up Steve is [ __ ] whatever
alright Steve this is what it is jesse
is out of the house
[Laughter]
if my team daughter gets pregnant inside
I'll be like yay baby what did you do so
progressive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]